hey David marianne williamson has ended
her presidential campaign how will this
affect the Democratic primary I don't
know if this is a joke because her
ending her campaign is of absolutely no
consequence but let's imagine that it is
not a joke
marianne williamson was polling 0.3
percent she hasn't been in a debate for
months her ending her campaign will have
absolutely no effect whatsoever on the
primary she was never a serious
candidate I interviewed her years ago
she seemed like a perfectly nice person
when I spoke to her she has some whacky
pseudoscience ideas her message of love
is fine we could all use more love and
less hate that all seems fantastic her
campaign struck me as a bit of a book
tour I can't think of any cabinet
position that marianne williamson would
be a good candidate for I think she may
actually be the least consequential
candidate who has dropped out of the
race so far I want to hear from you if
I'm missing something if this is a
serious question how will Marianne
ending her candidacy impact the
Democratic primary if you think it will
have any impact whatsoever I do want to
hear from you I don't see how it will
and if it's a joke of a question very
well done it's so subtle that I didn't
even notice we've got a great bonus show
coming up for you today it's Friday
meaning producer Pat takes the reins of
the bonus show I will be back on the
bonus show on Monday sign up instantly
instantly I'm talking instantly at join
pakman.com reminder for all of our
current and future chess players in the
audience Tuesday the 21st we will be
having our first ever David Pakman show
chess tournament ok 8:00 p.m. Eastern
Time I will livestream my participation
in the tournament starting at about 7:30
p.m. Eastern Time
the chess itself starts at 8:00 p.m. Lee
chess org is where we will be doing the
tournament allied chess org it's free
everything here is totally free doesn't
matter whether you play chess or not
everybody's welcome
the system will manage the tournament
it'll start matching the better players
against each other it all will work
beautifully it's going to be a great
time we're building community at the
David Pakman show I'm inviting you to
participate Tuesday February
first 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time in the
first-ever David Pakman show chess
tournament more about that on Monday off
to the bonus show for our members in
Paige